foreign
s us up next in Atlanta Aiden welcome to
the show how you doing
hey how's it going good good how are you
good I just man I've been so eager to
get some kind of professional advice
from someone and give you the best we
got well let me tell you you have
arrived at the right what is a
consummate today I don't know I mean
we're Pros aren't we George that's
self-proclaimed
what's going on Aiden
um so just real quick I'm 19 years old I
work for the fire department of my city
and they lowered the age limit so I was
able to be very fortunate be very
blessed to get in their career so young
right out of high school that's great
um I saved up quite a good bit before I
moved out of my mother's house and I
you know saved and saved but I still
ended up making you know the the young
foolish mistake of getting a place and
getting a car
um because in my head at the time I was
you know thinking well I want to stay
ahead of my age group I want to stay
ahead of my peers so why not get a place
with a mortgage and why not get a car
that I've always wanted
um and so I've accrued about 150 000 in
debt
um I've been able to maintain
responsibility and and continue to make
uh payments on it
um but I still really want my biggest
life goal is to have a legacy and create
generational wealth
um and really just continue to stay
ahead
um I was just wondering what your
thoughts and opinions on what I should
do next is what's the 150 in debt break
that down
so 125 is for this townhouse that I'm
staying in so it's your mortgage 100 uh
the mortgage
um it's I believe uh 10 50 a month okay
and what's the other 25
the other uh
so it's 150 the other part of it is the
car note
um and it the car that I got was I
believe around 30 okay and I'm making
payments on that as well and it's about
uh five six hundred every month
basically
um
I'm sorry what's your income
um I would say around 48 49 000 gross
okay
and here's what you told me you said you
want to create generational wealth but
your goals and your actions have so far
been misaligned and so I need to know
which one do you actually want
I know I can't have my cake and eat it
too
um but I definitely want but you said
you want to you want to get ahead of
your peers that's different than
generational wealth getting ahead with
your peers means looking good which
we've succeeded at so far generational
wealth means we're going to get out of
debt and have an inheritance to leave to
our children's children that's what that
means to me and so comparatively to your
income this is a lot of car
for a 19 year old
yes and my car is not worth this and I'm
a net worth millionaire and I'm going
the hoof for a 19 year old to step into
that that's a lot of car so what is the
car worth today
um as far as reselling it it's been
there's been a shortage on the make and
model that I got and that's why I wanted
it because I knew it was going to go
pretty fast which means you could sell
it for a pretty penny
right they're worth a little bit more so
how much could you sell it for
top dollar today uh probably 38. okay
and you owe how much left on the loan
um 30
I think it's like 30 and some change
okay so it would leave you with eight
grand
which you could pay for a used car it's
gonna be a whole lot dinkier than the
one you're driving now
but that puts you a whole lot closer to
becoming a net worth millionaire and
having generational wealth that just
leaves you with the mortgage right
yes sir and then making 50k and you're
19 it's going to continue to go up how
quickly could you pay off the mortgage
and begin investing for the future
um pretty soon I plan on picking up
extra work for another ambulance company
that's what I'm told here we go that's
what I wanted to hear I mean at your age
you want to get ahead George is right
you're working more hours man and in
your world firefighter ENT all that you
can get a lot of overtime presumably
correct
yes they they do a lot of different
bonuses and and different pop-ups here
and there for games and stuff like that
and transporting patients long distances
fantastic and I'm and I know I'm very
happy and fortunate to be in this field
because I know I have pretty well uh
Security in that field oh yeah you're
going to get a great retirement
situation there but then you're going to
follow the baby steps and and once you
pay this condo off for a town home or
whatever my friend that is you getting
way ahead of your peers and that you
have a cash property that you own and
you're investing 15 and you got your
fireman benefits and you've got overtime
possibilities and you have promotional
opportunities I mean it stands to
believe you could move pretty high up in
the fire uh Department uh by just the
simple fact that you started so young so
you've got a great future ahead of you
but you got to really listen to what
George said I mean he really challenged
you on the mindset side of this which is
what it takes to win with money
perspective
changes my belief
and believe changes my actions so George
is challenging you with a proper
financial perspective and then you begin
to see oh I believe that he's right I
believe that this is what I should do
and then before you know it you're
living differently acting differently
and that's the result amen so Aiden do
you have any savings
um I do have a thousand foot away okay
um I know that being so close paycheck
to paycheck has have already created me
like a good deal of anxiety which is why
I want to get more work because I don't
like the feeling of being in this you
know predicament and um you know just
watching the content on YouTube that's
available and like just hovering over as
we speak like the whole Financial Peace
University because my mom did it and
she's almost done with her mortgage and
um it's awesome of that nature
hey can I give you a an instant uh
ladder to a pay raise
can I do that for you sell the car today
sell the car today go get yourself an
eight thousand dollar car and go get
your roommate so now all of a sudden if
we get a roommate and let's just say we
split the uh mortgage because you've got
a roommate renting with you and you
charge 600 bucks yeah I mean
so now you freed up a 600 plus the car
payment so now you just got a twelve
hundred dollar raise
right that's before overtime my friend
and now we can start building that three
to six months emergency fund then we can
begin investing 15 whatever's left don't
forget the margin there's no anxiety
dude I feel more afraid just talking
about this with you Aiden
and so the question is and this is a
hard thing I'm not saying it's easy but
you've got to put the blinders on and go
I don't really care what my friends
think about what I drive because they're
going to see you driving that other car
and go dude what happened this ride
stinks you had such a cool car and he
went I'm trying to create generational
wealth and if they don't get that that's
fine and and I'm glad you bring that up
George Aiden can I give you another
little mini PEC talk uh George you know
the numbers on student loan the average
student loan you probably know this I
want you to add to it yep but I know
that the average college student is
spending almost six years
in trying to attain that degree
so I just want to give you a little
perspective that here you are working
right now
have got another five years before they
ever exit college and then they got the
student loan hanging around what's the
average yeah 38 000 I think is the
average amount so six years
to get out of school and then you walk
away on average with about forty
thousand dollars in debt and Aiden
that's not you so if you start feeling
like oh I'm worried about what
everybody's going to say about me I'd
run that reality through your head one
time and as you get older you
automatically start caring less and less
about what other people think but if you
do that at 19 dude you're gonna be light
years ahead
and that is the the best encouragement I
can give you because I remember being
your age and I was a knucklehead man I
was spending every dime I was making for
my jobs I was trying to I was buying
gear trying to impress people and then I
realized no one actually cares they're
all so focused on themselves and their
own insecurity and they're doing exactly
what you're doing and when you realize
we're all just running our own race as
insecure human beings you know just do
what's right for you yeah and remember
20 years from now Aiden you're probably
gonna walk out in your backyard your
neighbor will see you in a robe and tube
socks and flip-flops and you just don't
care we're all gonna be lame dance one
day just lean into it my friend hey
we're gonna gift you one year of
Financial Peace University so you can be
like Mom maybe go through it with her
it'll be a good time so hang on the line
we're going to gift you Financial Peace
University watch all the lessons do the
budget and you'll be on your path being
a millionaire my friend